Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Tag.
Aktuell ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz-Arzt tätig
und würde gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Bevor wir genau über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen, bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Hans-Peter Neumann.
Hans-Peter Neumann.
Und Herr Neumann, darf ich fragen, wie alt Sie sind?
Ja, 62 Jahre.
63.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,79 m.
Und zurzeit wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, 88 Kilogramm.
Okay.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Der Hausarzt ist Dr. Menzel.
Menzel.
Okay.
Haben Sie Angehörige, die wir benachrichtigen sollen?
Ja, meine Frau.
Okay, Herr Neumann.
Und was führt Sie zu uns, was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe seit gestern sehr stark Schmerzen im linken Bein.
Besonders im linken Unterschenkel.
Das ist seit gestern.
Das fing ziemlich schnell an.
Das begann sehr plötzlich.
Ja, und vorher hatte ich schon auch Schmerzen im Bein,
so vier Wochen vorher,
aber nur, wenn ich so mich bewegt habe,
wenn ich treppend gestiegen bin oder wenn ich zu Fuß gegangen bin,
dann traten diese Schmerzen auch mal auf,
aber nicht so stark wie gestern.
Seit gestern ist das ein Dauerschmerz.
Okay.
Könnten Sie genau die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie drückend, stehend?
Sie sind mehr so dumpf und auch bohrend, aber ziemlich stark.
Und können Sie die Schmerzen bis Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ja, das kann ich noch.
Und strahlende Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen aus?
Nein.
Und haben Sie ein Auslöser dafür bemerkt?
Auslöser habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Die Schmerzen sind plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ja, gesagt gestern.
Ziemlich plötzlich.
Und sind die Schmerzen konstant immer da oder kommen und gehen?
Sie sind immer da.
Immer da.
Und auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark ist.
Wie ist die Intensity?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Sieben.
Sie haben gesagt, diese Schmerzen seit vor Wochen, aber leichter waren.
Und früher waren die Schmerzen bewegungabhängig?
Ja, die waren mehr bei Bewegung.
Wenn ich gegangen bin oder so, wenn ich mich bewegt habe, dann traten die nach einer gewissen Zeit auf.
Wie lange konnten Sie laufen ohne Beschwerden?
Ungefähr 100 Meter.
Und dann mussten Sie ein bisschen warten?
Ja, da musste ich anhalten, stoppen und dann ging es nach 1, 2 Minuten wieder besser.
Und haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Nein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Nein, Herzrasen, Herzklopfen habe ich nicht.
Oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Husten?
Ja, Husten habe ich, aber ich glaube, das kommt vom Rauchen.
Meine Familie sagt, das kommt vom Rauchen, mein Husten.
Ich habe einen Rauchen.
Und wann haben Sie Husten?
Oh, 5 Jahre, 5 bis 10 Jahre, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Und sind der Husten trocken oder mit Auswurf?
Morgens habe ich manchmal Auswurf, da kommt Schleim raus, morgens.
Im Laufe des Tages nicht so sehr, aber morgens, nachdem ich aufgestanden bin.
Okay.
Die Schmerzen sind im Unterschenkel?
Hauptsächlich im linken Bein, im linken Unterschenkel, ja.
Mehr auf der Außenseite.
Aber der linke Unterschenkel tut schon sehr weh.
Gibt es eine Schwellung oder Rötung gerötet?
Nein, das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ich habe aber auch schon seit einigen Jahren,
habe ich häufig so ein Kribbelgefühl in beiden Beinen.
Auch etwas Taubheitsgefühl.
Da hat mein Arzt gesagt, ja, das kann mit meiner Zuckerkrankheit zu tun haben.
Zuckerkrankheit.
Und seit wann haben Sie Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, ungefähr seit sieben, acht Jahren muss ich eine Medikamente nehmen, eine Tablette.
Und die Kribbeln und Taubheitsgefühl sind momentan in rechten Beinen unterschenkelte?
Da sind die auch, ja, im rechten Bein auch.
Aber im Augenblick ist der Schmerz einfach in dem linken Unterschenkel,
der ist viel schlimmer.
Er ist schlimmer als jetzt das Kribbeln und Taubheitsgefühl.
Aber Kribbel und Taubhaut sind in beiden Beinen?
Ja, ja, in beiden Beinen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden wie Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Also Fieber und Schüttelfrost und Nachtschweiß habe ich nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit, Übelkeit, Schwindel?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich hatte Beschwerden, in der linken Hüfte habe ich Beschwerden.
Das ist bekannt, da war ich beim Orthopäden und der Orthopäde sagt,
ja, da ist eine beginnende Hüftartrose.
Es kann sein, hat er gesagt, dass ich in nächster Zeit operiert werden muss.
Aber das ist noch nicht sicher.
Aber ich habe da eine Art Rose in der linken Hüfte auch.
Sicher?
Ja, diese Hüfte Beschwerden habe ich jetzt vielleicht seit einem halben Jahr.
Und ich hatte vor einem Jahr, ich glaube vor drei Jahren war es,
da hatte ich einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Da hatte ich auch im linken Bein starke Schmerzen.
Und da wurde dann beim Orthopäden fünfmal Spritzen gesetzt.
Beim Orthopäden und durch die Spritzen und durch Krankengymnastik
ist das dann wieder besser geworden.
Was für Spritzen haben Sie gehabt?
Ich glaube, da war Cortison drin.
Cortison?
Ich glaube.
Wegen Bandscheiben vollfrei.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit normalerweise?
Der Appetit ist zu gut.
Ich muss aufpassen, auch wegen dem Zucker und wegen meinem Gewicht.
Ich habe ja ein bisschen zu viel Gewicht.
Aber ja, es fällt mir schwer.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit auch Untersuchern genommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang?
Das ist regelmäßig.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Was erlassen, habe Sie Probleme bei?
Ich muss manchmal zweimal in der Nacht auf Toilette wasserlassen.
Aber das stört mich nicht.
Ich kann danach wieder gut einschlafen.
Gibt es eine Ursache dafür?
Ich war einmal beim Urologen.
Der hat gesagt, die Prostata ist etwas vergrößert.
Das kann daran liegen.
Aber wenn mich das im Augenblick nicht weiter beeinträchtigt,
dann kann ich erst mal so fortführen.
Und ich soll jetzt im August wieder zur nächsten Vorsorgeuntersuchung
auch zum Urologen.
Okay.
Herr Neumann, haben Sie Allergien?
Nein.
Gut.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie sind Raucher.
Ja.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche schon 40 Jahre.
40 Jahre?
Pro Tag ungefähr eine Schachtel.
Eine Schachtel.
Okay.
Herr Neumann, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Wie euch trinke abends zu einem bis zwei Flaschen Bier trinke ich abends.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Auch ungefähr seit 40 Jahren.
Okay.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Gut.
Okay.
Ich möchte genau wissen, Sie haben schon erwähnt,
dass Sie Bulupzuka haben seit sieben, acht Jahren.
Und sonst haben Sie leider andere Erkrankungen.
Ja, einen anderen chronischen Erkrankungen.
Ich habe hohen Blutdruck.
Das habe ich seit zehn Jahren.
Da nehme ich auch Medikament.
Welche Medikament nehmen Sie?
Also gegen einen hohen Blutdruck nehme ich Kandisatan.
Und bis dann Sie zwei Tabletten.
Zwei Tabletten pro Tag nehme ich von Kandisatan.
Eine morgens und eine abends.
Und wie viele Ligren?
Da steht acht.
Acht.
Okay.
Und da nehme ich auch noch zwei Zuckertabletten.
Zuckertabletten.
Welche Tabletten?
Das habe ich hier stehen.
Medformin heißt das.
Dahinter steht 850.
840 mg.
Einmalz, Weimar.
Morgens eine Tablette und abends.
Morgens und abends.
Und noch andere?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Tabletten ein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Also wie gesagt, die Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck,
dann die Hüftarthrose.
Weiß ich, ob das chronisch ist.
Und wie gesagt, vor drei Jahren diesen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Ja, sonst habe ich aber keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Gut.
Herr Neumann, wurde Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind, da war ich, glaube ich, zehn Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert.
Und dann wurde ich ein Jahr später am Leistenbruch operiert
auf der rechten Seite.
Und vor einem Jahr wurde ich an der linken Hand operiert.
Am Handgelenk, weil meine Finger immer eingeschlafen sind,
da wurde ein Nerv freigelegt, wie es heißt, entlastet.
Und nach der Operation ist das auch besser geworden.
Da schlafen die Finger nicht mehr ein.
Wann haben Sie Handgelenk-Opera gehabt?
Das war vor einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr.
Okay.
Und Leistenbruch?
Leistenbruch, da war ich, glaube ich, elf Jahre alt.
Okay.
Und gibt es chronische Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Herr Neumann.
In der Familie?
Ja, der Vater, der ist mit 78 Jahren verstorben.
Der hatte wohl an der Bauchschlachader,
wie nennt sich das, eine Aussackung.
Diese Aussackung ist wo geplatzt.
Da ist er verblutet an dieser Hauptschlachader.
Da ist er verstorben.
Und die Mutter, die ist 86 Jahre alt, die lebt noch.
Die ist ziemlich verwirrt, glaube ich, Alzheimer.
Und hat eine starke Lungenüberblähung, wie es heißt.
Die kriegt schlecht Luft.
Und dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, der ist 58 Jahre alt.
Der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Bruder ist 58?
58.
Und hat Bluthoch?
Hohen Blutdruck, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Geschülste und nur einen Bruder?
Einen Bruder nur.
Okay.
Und Herr Neumann, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Schornsteinfeger.
Ah, gut.
Schornsteinfeger.
Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein.
Die Arbeit ist zwar manchmal anstrengend, weil wir müssen bei,
auch bei schlechtem Wetter, manchmal auf die Dächer plättern,
aber insgesamt gesehen ist die Arbeit nicht sehr stressig.
Gut.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder, die sind 31 Jahre alt und 33 Jahre alt.
Die wohnen aber nicht mehr bei uns.
Und ja, den geht es gut, die sind gesund.
Okay, gut.
Sind Sie geimpft gegen Kinderhalt, Krankheiten, Corona?
Also sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich war im Oktober beim Hausarzt und er hat nochmal den
Impfpass angeschaut und hat dann eine Impfung gemacht gegen
Verzündung und gegen Corona.
Das war jetzt im Ende Oktober, Anfang November und auch gegen
Grippe.
Und sonst habe ich gut geimpft.
Gut.
Und sind Sie in Westerseite ins Ausland gereist?
Ja, ich war in Spanien im September.
Ich war zwei Wochen in Spanien.
Aber sonst war ich die letzten Urlaube immer in Deutschland.
Gut.
Okay, also Herr Neumann, möchten Sie etwas dazu hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Das kann ich haben.
Das macht mir schon Sorgen, dieser starke Schmerz,
dein Bein, der geht ja gar nicht weg.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Bevor präfaire Untersuchung und Labor-Untersuchung,
leider kann ich nicht genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Aber vermutlich, Sie haben Probleme mit Ihrer Artilien,
also Gefäß, Gefäsen, weil Sie haben diese Schmerzen
beim Bewegung.
Also diese Beschwerden sprechen eher für eine Gefäßkrankheit.
Okay.
Gut, aber das werden Sie jetzt ja dann untersuchen
und feststellen, was die Ursache ist.
Ja, genau.
Gut, dann würde ich jetzt sagen, haben Sie jetzt 10 Minuten Zeit,
etwas vorzubereiten und die Patientensprache zu übersetzen.
Denken Sie an Differenzialdiagnose vielleicht.
Gibt es von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Ergänzungsfragen?
Ja.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie gemerkt, die Beinhaut belästigt ist?
Die Haut.
Ähnlich hat der Kollege gefragt, ob die Haut, glaube ich,
verändert ist oder warmes.
Die Haut hat sich nicht groß verändert.
Ich habe den Eindruck, die Haut links im Unterschenkel
ist kühler als rechts.
Okay, danke.
Gibt es sonst noch eventuelle Ergänzungsfragen bezüglich der Beine?
Ich denke, alle haben eine Giste.
Man könnte höchstens noch fragen nach einem eventuellen Unfallereignis
um noch sicher zu gehen.
Also ein Unfallereignis in den letzten 2 Monaten
kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Ich bin nicht gestürzt oder so etwas.
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Könnten Sie beschreiben, wo die Schmerzen genau lokalisieren?
Also in ganz Bein oder in der Wade?
Im linken Unterschenkel und so mehr in der Wade,
aber auch mehr auf der Außenseite.
Da spürt es.
Das war so ähnlich, da war der Schmerz auch,
als ich den Bandscheibenvorfall hatte vor 3 Jahren.
Da war ja nicht ein Bandscheibenvorfall.
Und da hatte ich diese Schmerzen auch im linken Bein.
Die waren aber ein bisschen anders, aber da war der Schmerz auch.
Ja, und verstärken Ihre Schmerzen besonders bei einem Bewegung?
Das war in den letzten Wochen so,
aber seit gestern habe ich einen Dauerschmerz.
Da möchte ich mich auch gar nicht bewegen.
Kann ich gar nicht gut.
Aber ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich das Bein richtig legen soll,
weil es tut immer weh.
Wir haben ja so, sagen wir mal, 3 Komplexe bei den Patienten.
Es ist einmal dieses seit 4 Wochen bestehende
belastungsabhängiger Schmerz.
Seit gestern ein Dauerschmerz.
Der Patient berichtet über eine Hüftarthrose links,
die wohl zunimmt, wo der Orthopäde gesagt hat,
eventuell muss sie bald operiert werden.
Wir haben einen Zustand nach Bandscheibenvorfall vor 3 Jahren
auf der linken Seite.
Und wir haben seit einem Jahr ungefähr ein Taubheiz- und Kribbelgefühl
in beiden Beinen.
Das sind die wesentlichen Faktoren,
die dann auch in der Schilderung nachher
auch in der möglichst medizinischen Sprache
wiedergegeben werden sollen.
Auch, was die Differenzialdiagnose angeht.
Herr Dasch, du bist bereit?
Wir können gerne anfangen.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Hans-Peter Neumann.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns vor,
aufgrund seit gestern bestehender, daurenhaftige,
dumpfartige, bohrenden Schmerzen in der Warte.
In welcher Warte?
In der Linke Warte.
Darüber hinaus berichtete er,
in der Linke Warte
hat sie schon seit 4 Wochen belastungabhängige Schmerzen.
Und im Laufe der Zeit haben die Schmerzen zugenommen
und seit gestern unerträglich.
Und der Schmerzinterstate liegt bei 7 von 10 auf eine Schmerzskala.
Früher konnten sie nur 100 Meter laufen ohne Besperren.
Dann musste er ein paar Minuten anhalten.
Die Frage nach Herz, Tachikardi und Tachikini und Dispner
wurden verneint.
Er leiderte unter Husten seit 5 bis 10 Jahren
mit schleimiger Sputum.
Diese Beschwerden treten meistens morgens.
Die Frage nach Unfall ist auch verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis Nectury unauffällig.
Also er leider unter Nectury.
Und er hat deswegen sein Rheologer besucht
und bei ihm ist festgestellt eine Prostat,
Benin Prostat Hyperplosy.
Und keine Allergien ist bekannt.
Er ist Raucher 40 Package Years
und trinkt täglich ein bis zwei Flasche Bier
und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er leider seit 7 bis 8 Jahren
unter Diabetes Melitus Tip 2.
Und dagegen nimmt er Metformin ein,
850 Milligramm morgens und abends.
Er klagte über Kribbeln und Taubheitsgefühl in beiden Beinen.
Darf ich unterbrechen?
Gibt es noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Er hat auch Coxartrose.
Auf welcher Seite?
Coxartrose, linken Seite auch.
Und seit drei Jahren leidet er an Bandscheiben,
also Discus prolapsus.
Also vor drei Jahren bestand eine Lumboischialgie.
Wahrscheinlich bei Bandscheiben, Discus prolaps.
Aber gibt es noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Sie haben eine vergessen?
Er hat auch Arteriellaehypertony seit zehn Jahren.
Und dagegen nimmt er Kandisartan, 8 Milligramm morgens und abends.
Okay, dieser Discus prolaps, wie wurde der behandelt?
Hat er da noch Beschwerden der Patient?
Ja, er war beim Orthopäden und mit Spritzen,
wahrscheinlich Koalitionsspritzen behandelt.
Also lokale Injektionen?
Ja, lokale Injektionen.
Gut.
Ich habe sie eben unterbrochen.
Entschuldigung, Sie haben berichtet von Beinbeschwerden bei den Patienten.
Können Sie das noch mal sagen, was der Patient sonst noch hat seit einem Jahr?
Bein kribbelt, also Parästhesie und Tapheizgefühl.
Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Also, ich habe es jetzt verstanden.
Der 62-jährige Patient hat seit einem Tag sehr starke Schmerzen im linken Bein,
besonders im linken Unterstattung.
Dieser Schmerz war leichter schon in den letzten vier Wochen bei Belastung.
Er konnte 100 Meter, circa freie Gehstrecke gehen,
wahrscheinlich im Sinne einer Claudicatiointermittenz.
Und der Patient hatte vor drei Jahren eine Lumboyl-Gelastung.
Er hatte eine Lumboyl-Gelastung.
Wahrscheinlich bei Discosprolaps,
die vom Orthopäden mit lokalen Indiektionen behandelt wurde.
Wahrscheinlich auch noch mit Physiotherapie.
Hat der Patient diesbezüglich dennoch Beschwerden gehabt
oder ist er jetzt diesbezüglich beschwerdefrei?
Diesbezüglich, denke ich.
Der Patient hat diese Spritzenbehandlung und Physiotherapie geholfen.
Das war in Ordnung.
Dann hat er die Coxarthrose, links,
die sich nach Schilderung des Patienten in letzter Zeit verschlimmert hat.
Dann haben sie noch berichtet,
hat der Patient wohl einen erheblichen Nikotin-Abusus.
Sie haben gesagt, 40 Packages.
Das ist schon eine starke Dosis.
Was können Sie noch berichten über die Familie?
Die Familie Annamnese ist der Vater mit 58 Jahren.
Ich dachte, 78.
Mit 78.
78 Jahre ist ein Alt-Aneurysmaruptor verstorben.
Wahrscheinlich Baucherorten-Aneurysma.
Die Mutter ist 86 Jahre alt.
Sie lebt noch, aber wahrscheinlich hat sie Alzheimer.
Vielleicht auch COPD.
Oder Mfisema.
Wahrscheinlich Mfisema.
Das wissen wir nicht genau.
Sein Bruder ist 58 Jahre alt und hat Arterialehipertoni.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Aufgrund der annamnestischen Angaben gehe ich von einer Periphera-Arterialverschluß-Krankheit.
Schaufenster-Krankheit, so genannte.
Diese Krankheit ist eine arterielle Krankheit.
Wahrscheinlich handelt es sich um einen Gefäßverschluss.
Der Patient hat seit einem Tag sehr starke Schmerzen.
Schalasieben, dumpf, bohrend.
Man kann befürchten, dass ein Gefäß verschlossen ist.
Wahrscheinlich unterhalb der Arteria poplitea.
Was ist Ihre Differenzialdiagnose?
Die Differenzialdiagnose kommt von einem TVT, Tif-Bennon-Trombose.
Eine andere Differenzialdiagnose kann ich momentan nicht sagen.
Es kann mit Rheinspielen ein Bandscheibenvorfall sein.
Es kann in die Wade einstrahlen.
Man muss zumindest in Erwägung ziehen.
Der Patient hat eine Vorgeschichte.
Der Patient hat, wie Sie selber sagen, die Kribbelparästhesien.
Wie würden Sie die sagen?
Als Diabetische Neuropathie.
Wenn er eine Diabetische Neuropathie entwickelt.
Wir wissen nicht genau, wie viel Alkohol er trinkt.
Er gibt dann ein bis zwei Flaschen Bier.
Er hat eine Vorgeschichte.
Er hat eine Prolapsis.
Er hat eine Koksartrose.
Er hat mehrere Möglichkeiten.
Er hat ein Beinschmerz.
Er hat eine Verdacht auf einen akuten Gefäßverschluss.
Deshalb muss man relativ zügig eine Diagnostik machen.
Um eventuell eine Gefäßintervention zu machen.
Um das Gefäß wieder zu eröffnen.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt.
Ich finde, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Sehr strukturiert.
Die wesentlichen Dinge haben ich auch in der Anamnese benannt.
Die wesentlichen Fachbegriffe haben ich gut reproduziert.
Das fand ich gut.
Man hat Ihre Prüfung gemacht.
Man hat die Anamnese gut produziert.
Awohl?
Sehen wir uns jede Woche ab.
Ihre Prüfung?
8. april habe ich?
8. april.
Sehen wir uns nächste Woche.